oh and welcome to dear Hank and John a
more properly dear Greg it's a comedy
podcast for me and my brother John and
sometimes special guests answer your
questions give you this advice and give
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon today we have Greg game
over Greggy Oh kind of funny that's
right all of the things did you do
welcome
I do a lot of things on the Internet I
do stuff like that I guess what not yet
I mean with the thing that I was sort of
amazed like I was like I wonder if Greg
would want to be a guest John on dear
Hank and John and you responded in like
13 seconds and I know you've got the
Twitter beams right to my brain Twitter
beams right to my brain I keep missing
you have a lot that you do and you do it
every day and I am always very impressed
and I kind of want to because I also
feel that people feel this way about me
and I always want to talk to other
people about how they manage their very
busy lives and not destroy their brain
or bodies sure okay what would you like
to know just that just know I manage I
don't really well you know I always tell
this story right before we left there
are little jobs I was talking to
co-workers before vacation before
Christmas vacation which would be you
know us quitting and they were like hey
I'm like you gotta be looking forward to
so I'm like dude it's gonna be the best
I go home from work now and I get these
tension headaches right around my
temples I've noticed I'm starting to go
gray there but when I go out and I do
this we start our own business we'll set
our own schedule it'll be so relaxed and
I am so all over great it just sucks it
out of you you know I know I know what
you mean I I've managed to dodge the
gray hair bullet so far as a 37 year old
I have like six of them but but I I'm
keeping keeping an eye on it I do have
this is what I have is my eyebrow hairs
are starting to be old man eyebrow hairs
and they're like I'm gonna be it's like
I would have come down into your eyes I
want to be down there this is yeah I'm
the the boot and Katherine my wife is
like not having a moment of it she just
bit I'll be sitting there watching TV
and it's
like what just happened to my face she's
plucking my eyebrows I was gonna say she
on patrol that's great that's a great
wife
you need that I need that you need to
keep you know your YouTube in podcast
that's right that's right it's all about
like really no one thinks about the
importance of eyebrow size in the
appearance of youth I'm still getting
carded but only because Catherine's
plucking my eyebrows exactly it's one of
those things you take for granted it's
not so you see a really bad set of
eyebrows we're like oh man that's I
think people need to pay attention to
use like going all Eugene Levy Anya it
is a yeah it is it's interesting to
watch my body change as I get older I
also just had a baby and I was in an
airport last night eating food and when
I should clearly like my fifth meal of
the day and I google she's having a baby
make men gain weight and yes it does
there's a fair amount of research done
on this if you have a baby even if you
don't live with the baby just having a
baby makes you gain weight yeah it's
just it's too much it's on your mind
you're probably not sleeping as well as
you used to it also changes your body
hormones like things change when you
have a baby even for guys certainly not
on the road no use not on yeah of course
not on the level of so yeah you should
count your lucky stars that many gray
hairs yeah running kind of funny this
YouTube twitch podcast Empire we have
here it's yeah we do is spin plates at
any point one of these plates could fall
down hopefully we have enough other ones
spinning on okay on our ass and cents or
something to keep it going yeah that is
that is the trick you're diversified as
they say in exactly as this we have a
tripod business approach you know I mean
you take one way got the other legs will
support yeah I have like a like a 55
legged stool is really the way you want
it to work exactly like one of those
wobbly tables you get it or a rest
when you go in and we fold the coaster
inputs than over the legs there's a lot
of that happening because it yeah
for every leg of the stool you get a new
gray hair which which is you know I
think you're doing pretty well then
thank you yeah if that my gray hair
would definitely establish that as a
running this video game comedy podcast
true by here
so I heard that you were able to scrunch
together a short poem for us I was I
looked around the internet and you know
I know there's a long history of poems
here John brings good stuff usually yeah
but I figured if I'm coming in here I
had to find something that really spoke
to who I am and gave you our listeners a
great window into regular from kinda
funny years so this one is from jest
Mel's he posted it online June 2014
it's titled Superman versus Batman like
Superman to your Batman
I actually got power power with ink
power with flow don't even blink
I'll make your mind blow just letting
you know what I'm coming from everybody
hello poetry calm I mean I it's hello
poetry calm hello like we're saying I
well I I don't know why our podcast
isn't the hello poetry calm podcast I'll
tell you they seem to have a lot of
stuff because it's like yeah the top of
it it says words Superman is highlighted
obviously but on the other side clearly
showing all the other words they can
pull from you have superior superiority
Superman Supermarket supernatural Wow
Supermarket poems okay you know what I'm
clicking under right now let's see what
we got oh here we go
oh the first one we read you DJ Goodwin
July 2013 supermarket retailing hunter
oh sorry
retail hunter gatherers pick clean
process
it's digging graves with their shiny
teeth studious in the reveries as they
drone swirls dumped in the Thresher oh
it kept have struck in fields of film
wrapped I mean they're deep on now you
you think hello poetry might not happen
they got it they got it
I mean that poem goes on for a while oh
it's dead stairs he keeps going I think
I think God I think we got the gist
though I do Mitchum I dis fora and the
Arctic wasteland cased in sliding glass
fields of perfect steady storms and his
rapes baked and halogen asked silent
questions oh man silver beet I tell you
what like I was just at the grocery
store and I didn't feel any of those
feelings I was like I would like a
sandwich and he was like that'll be a
couple minutes and then I make sure I
also bought like some mango slices for
my baby
pre mangoes so annoying and it's amazing
that somebody cut this mango up for me
so I don't have to do it there are so
many Superman poems you know she should
be the world's most popular I mean is
he's a good metaphor at the very least
anyway in the future we will do the
hello
poetry podcast but that's that's not
what we are here to do today do you want
to answer or ask and answer some
questions from our listeners Greg I
would love you
alright well I'll let us with our first
one and then you can do the second one I
really want to get to this and so I'm
just kind of gonna start with it it's
from Andrea who asks dear Hank and Greg
I'm currently trying to study but I keep
hitting distracted by the no food sign
in the library I know this question
doesn't lend itself to a podcast but it
is I know this question doesn't lend
itself well to a podcast but it's the
middle piece of food in the attached
picture a slab of raw ham perhaps an
oddly sliced beet I need to know Andrea
will put this picture up on the patreon
you don't have to be a patron to look at
it just so that everybody can see what
we're talking about
it was clearly three items of what has
been labeled food there's an apple there
is a piece of bread and Greg what is
that little thing maybe a whole loaf
maybe we're right right right I like I
like us more like a roll maybe a roll of
bread
there is clearly a slice of what appears
to be some kind of meat but with the
giant white centre indicating there's a
bone yeah it is maybe just the leg of a
cow it's it looks maybe like a steak it
also maybe it looks like a piece of
bread that it's been dyed red and maybe
it's got like the egg and a whole thing
going where they cut it and they put it
in they cut like the middle out of the
bread and correct an egg into it
and that but it's yes have you ever seen
it on the internet when they'll do the
whole thing of like the rain and the
grab people like all right cool draw
party for a memory try right Pikachu for
huh it strikes me as somebody grab
somebody was like I know you've watched
a Looney Tunes episode before where
they're eating me cut what do you think
the me draw a piece of meat right now
and they took like when you have the
giant turkey bone or ham bone right then
rather than because it looks like the
end of that where you see the bone and
then surrounded by pink but then someone
took like a circular saw and sue pawed
through the book to then put it down
right treating it as if it were a loaf
of bread it just took a slice of exactly
right down the middle of that turkey leg
I yeah yeah I think that it's probably
intended to be raw steak like raw red
yeah which does seem like an like I
agree you should not eat raw red meat in
the library that's a good I mean that's
a good tip for life yeah I don't know if
you can this with steak tartare but if
somebody cut this and dropped it on a
plate to me I'd be like no sir this is
not correct
also it clearly in the photo is touching
the both the rustic bread and the apple
and so both of those yeah you can't have
either of them anymore
no which is a shame that bread and
because slice to discover slices of
apple on that rustic bread and I'm down
so I think that I think that it is
perfectly natural for you Andrea to have
been distracted by this very peculiar
slice of beet bread it's very much have
you seen this other one going around
I started red
now but it was like after last month's
incident Oreos are no longer a lot of
library other cookies are fine but the
entire institution of like Numa knows
all right no problem you want to bring
the chips away in here we yeah there
must have been an Oreo fight you'd think
so you think it was maybe a scavenger
hunt where people were hiding Oreos
right and now there's like still there
forever and cuz you didn't find out the
Oreos and there's ants now and then they
dance they eat the beard in the book
book glue and that's never good because
that's that's how books come together do
you do you want to hit us with that next
question Greg sure let's jump to Nicole
Nicole writes it it says dear John and
Hank it's okay I wasn't supposed to be
around two and a half years ago I met a
girl that moved to my town slash school
we became best friends like ultra best
bros friends my mom didn't like her
saying that she was a bad influence and
such and we had a lot of fights about it
but we remained almost sisters my friend
has severe depression and anxiety I've
always been there for her and she's
relied a lot on me however a few months
ago she moved away and we stopped
talking and seeing each other as much
during this time I have come to notice
that I did really miss her my mental
health improved incredibly and so was my
relationship with my mother now I have
the opportunity to talk to her again but
I don't really want you and my friends
keep talking to me like I'm her other
half which is really uncomfortable if I
tell her what's happened I know it will
affect her greatly and not in a good way
what do I do you are isn't worried
Nicole Nicole that is a super hard
situation to be in and I will start out
by recognizing that and and also
commending you for recognizing the the
complexity of the situation that you're
in right now which is that there there
is you and you want to take care of you
but you also care about your friend and
you want to also care about her and not
hurt that person but it does seem that
you are aware that you like who is you
know if you know you need to be taking
care of yourself first so if you are in
a place where you feel like you can take
care of yourself and also lend a little
bit of support to this other person then
there is an opportunity there to do that
if you don't feel like you have that if
you don't feel like you're able to help
that person without dragging yourself
down without pulling yourself into a
place you don't want to be anymore
then it that is not your obligation yeah
she doesn't feel she has to be attached
this person right and I feel like just
what she says here in the fact that
she's in a better spot now right yeah
you think even about that she didn't
really missed this friend I think that
says a lot about where you guys are at
it's okay you know to not be friends
it's okay to end on good terms and move
away from each other and go on and have
different relationships with different
people I feel like that might be what
this is yeah yeah and we've actually got
another question coming up later in the
podcast maybe we should just loop it in
about what that the you know somebody's
sort of asking hey I have never had a
friend that I feel like it's gonna be my
friend forever and asking us like who
are our oldest friends and how long have
we had those friends I'm curious what's
your answer that question what's your
oldest treasure I mean my my oldest
friend is a name it's a boy named Pope
who I've known I've known him since I
guess first grade and okay 34 right now
yeah we I want to say we became best
friends and so probably right before
high schools like seventh or eighth
grade somewhere in there but ever since
then yeah and we've been those kind of
friends that you know we went to high
school together then went off to
different colleges me and Missouri him
up in Minnesota and when we pick back up
we pick back up like nothing changed
like yeah I know each other that well we
are we are brothers to that extent where
I think we went through so much together
that we don't need to check in with each
other every week but when we do every
few
months to catch up on what's happening
or when I come back together it's like
nothing changed yeah yeah that is that's
really wonderful it's funny that you
said his that he was a boy
because yeah no he's not anymore he's 34
years old
yeah childhood friends yeah I'm still
jump back to remember that time you
peeps in the car yeah I I didn't I don't
have that as much with any of my friends
from like elementary age I don't know
any of those folks anymore I do I am
still very close with all the people I
hung out when I was like 16 17 18 like
late late high school times and still
hang out with them hopefully once a year
once every two years and you know always
am in touch with those folks and you
know I like this person is 17 years old
and doesn't feel like their this is
Tiffany now has any friends that that
Tiffany's gonna be friends with you know
until she's 30 like we are now
yeah and that's okay like that's fine
100% and you like I feel like sorry
friends come in and out and there is an
amount of like loyalty that can kind
like that that maybe is sometimes
expected to friends that maybe is a
little bit too much like if it's or if
it's something that is important to you
and that you want to that you you want
to keep that going and you want to find
ways to make those relationships
productive and long-term absolutely do
that it's like one of the great things
in life but it is it is energy and
upkeep so you want to make sure that
you're spending that energy on the
people that you want to keep in your
life forever for a long time exactly and
you figure in my case right pose the
outlier like I have a bunch of other
friends that I do in junior high in high
school but I don't talk to them anymore
and like when you get to college that's
where I made a bunch of what I would see
like adult friends right friends that
I'm still close to or talk to but even
then we're talking three people yeah my
you know five and a half years in
Missouri that I keep in touch with
actively I wanna you know spend time
with and come back and visit or hear
about their kids or whatever it not just
having Kirsten
Facebook content content like I still
think you have the chance to make those
friendships to make those connections
and it doesn't it doesn't reflect on you
it isn't a bad thing that you already
haven't done that at 17 yeah absolutely
we had a sensor to look at us we're not
gonna stop I think what you said though
is great about like you know expected
loyalty and what best friends means like
that's different for every person and if
you're many people that you like and
you're friends with but you don't want
to be invested on that level and that's
totally fine yeah but I do like I think
it's important to recognize it's been
important for me to recognize I should
say that a great deal of joy and like
stability is brought into my life by my
friends and and and sometimes I will be
like so to take that for granted or I'll
be like well yeah but I've got so much
other stuff going on and a baby and I've
got my marriage and I've got my family
and I've got my business and like it's
just hard to do that but to put to
dedicate some time and think like I
think of everything as projects now
because I've broken my brain and to
dedicate time to that to the management
of the project of friendships is really
important I has been really important
for me for my like mental health and my
happiness even though it never seems
like when my top priority is never
hanging out with my buds because I have
a child so that's always gonna be the
top priority this thing it just pooped
in its pants again and that is the that
is the thing that I need to be taken
care of right now but the but it is I
think it is you know it's not something
when I was younger it would it just took
care of itself like it just happened
because I was always available to hang
out and you know and that but like
trying to keep those relationships
maintained is more than just like a
Facebook thing where I'm reading about
them on whatever they're posting it is
it's an active project and it's
something that that pays dividends for
me and and I think that it's easy for
those things to sort of fall apart when
you don't like sort of ena
actively like it's one thing to be like
I think probably it's not healthy like
I'm not in a place where I can help this
person out anymore
versus like I love this person but like
I don't need to maintain the
relationship because like they like it's
all going pretty well but then it all
falls apart and you haven't talked in
five years so that's just something I've
been thinking about generally with
regards to friends and how thankful I am
to have good good friends yeah I think
yeah I'm assuming for you but I know for
me for sure like having the friends I
have that are in the friends who've been
around for a while or knew me before I
moved to San Francisco or stuff to that
effect like they helped keep me grounded
right because I think it's so easy to
get caught up my day to day yeah well
this video game code didn't come in or
all disembark is happening or we have to
go I'm gonna go to LA tomorrow to go
speak to a bunch of fans and I'm
stressed out of my packing and I talk to
people who lead normal lives
professor I'm a doctor alright you
talking about their children you're like
right there there's a bigger world honey
here than me wanting soccer comic books
yeah I forget yep that is that is very
that is very good for maybe us in
particular what's real what's important
yeah yeah and and provide a different
diversity of worldview and and also just
a relaxation if you can get it from them
which is great this next question comes
from radical who asks dear Hank and Greg
my recently my friends have been arguing
about whether or not water is wet they
say that water is obviously wet and that
wetness is an inherent property of water
I however think that wetness is what
happens when previously dry objects are
covered by water any dubious advice on
the topic would be super helpful like
radical without the L radical thank you
for the pronunciation guide I was gonna
say rap is a great name this is radical
name what do you think yeah waters wet I
think it's so wet that it's gone beyond
the
the definition of wet in the hider is
saying I understand the argument that
okay is it but what got wet the molecule
[Laughter]
well I think that there's there's two
ways to look at it and but but I
definitely first of all I think that
technically water is not wet I think
that if you look at the definition of
what wetness is it is sure where it is
when something got wet and water didn't
get wet but it is but it's just but it's
so wet it's so when it doesn't need to
get wet it's oh yeah I I I'm gonna I'm
gonna stick firm and say that you have
to be something that isn't water with
water on you in order for you to I mean
the definition here on the Internet the
state of condition of being covered or
saturated with water or another liquid
dampness but is it me is it water
saturated with water isn't it the most
saturated with water thing that you can
have see you just like as a hot dog
sandwich and you read the definition of
a sandwich like I don't know it kind of
could be it's not hot dogs not sandwich
we got I don't want to get into the
definitions of it waters wet it kind of
upsets me it kind of upsets me that we
could actually live in a world in which
like it feels like water needs to be wet
for like the world to make sense but I
think that it's not wet
I think it's not wet it's really weird
to me so I'm gonna go on a tangent here
it is weird to here we go
wait you could you could wet ice so you
could get a piece of ice that's really
really cold and thus dry sure it's not
wet and then put water on it so you
could wet water in that way but this
isn't the tangent the
engin tis so all the stuff we eat all
the stuff we put into our bodies is like
mostly like life stuff like plants and
animals and and and yes there's portions
of those plants and animals that are
inorganic things like you know potassium
and vitamins or whatever I don't know so
there's there's definitely inorganic
stuff that's that you're that you're
eating and that are important to your
body that you need in order to function
but water is really weird in that it's a
mineral it is a it's a it is not a
living thing it's not an organic
compound it is a mineral it is like it
is like a frozen like ice is just
another rock basically and then but we
need to drink this mineral all day long
in order to not die immediately it's
yours we have to feel weird
you have to fill up our weird meat sacks
with wetness in order to be alive and we
have to make our insides win for sure ah
with water that's also wet it is
important to keep the insides wet dry so
what all right all right I think water
is dry is definitely the new
controversial opinion that that like
doesn't matter and that I will defend
with my life take that I'm just gonna
tweet it no context water is dry exactly
see how that one goes all right what
else do we got you got another question
for me I feel like we've covered this
one we got we have another one here but
it's the same idea where it's gonna be
us arguing scratching heads unless we
want actually get into it brooke writes
in and says Hank and John again I feel
Hank you didn't promote me enough
the orange is named oranges because they
are orange or as the color orange called
orange because oranges are orange the
word orange has lost all meaning to be
fruity frenzy what does I mean yeah you
definitely did that to all of our brains
that is it was a very well it's like
that it's like Buffalo buffalo Buffalo
buffalo Buffalo buffalo Buffalo buffalo
except except there were like some words
that weren't orange in that sentence I
actually looked this up if you want to
the real answer hold on yeah I do but
before we do what I want to take a guess
I got to think okay okay so just named
oranges because they are orange or as
the color orange called orange because
oranges are orange I'm gonna say wait
what if there is there is a third option
here that the word orange in the color
like the fruit orange in the color
orange aren't not linguistically related
that have been some rules there are
situations where and in fact there is
this there are some places called orange
like town names and those that come
actually well that Orange County comes
from from oranges but in England I think
there's like a town named orange and
that actually comes from a different
name a different like a linguistic root
then the color orange and the fruit
orange but but they are linked the color
and the fruit are X are linked that is
not that I guess my guess is gonna be
the color came first and then cuz I also
know that like human beings just aren't
that imaginative so somebody saw an
orange and was like oh it's it's like
the sky or the color orange so we're
gonna name that orange you these are
incorrect damn it we actually named the
colors relatively late considering how
we treat family so we like colors when
we're teaching children like it's one of
the first things they learn is like you
were trying to be like this is a blue
fish and this is an orange fish and like
teaching that relationship is part of
cognitive development and and like that
you can apply labels to something and it
is still a fish but it is a
different colored fish or it's a big
fish or a small fish or whatever
sure so so if we use colors in that way
a lot and so it seems to us in the today
world that colors are a very basic
property but I listen to a podcast once
in which I in which they hit me with the
the very slow and and like not all at
once
inclusion of different colors into
vocabularies and it happened quite
slowly and orange the color was drawn
out of orange the fruit and orange
interestingly the word that we you know
the sort of root of the word orange is
really old because apparently had
oranges for a long time and it's one of
the not very many words in English that
is actually from Sanskrit and yeah and
it sounds pretty similar to more similar
to like the Spanish word for orange than
our word for orange which is like neuron
ha or neurons and then we some and I
think the French took it and made it
into something more like orange and then
we turned it into oranges so that's the
situation with oranges also maybe
because if it's weird root is why there
are not very many words that rhyme with
it or not depending on how you count I
did a bunch of research on the word
orange well Brooke needed in the hints
are Greg and God bless you for being
that far yeah yep this question next
question Greg comes from Meghan who and
I've just fits good taste in your name
and because that because you're here it
says doing though you're trying to make
it look like you planned this at all
rather than just grabbing me off the
streets well it is what you do I mean
yeah true it comes from Meghan who asks
dear Hank and Greg I have been cursed
with both a very common first name and a
very common last name my name is Megan
Johnson and I've always grown up with
multiple Megan's or
in every activity and every class there
was almost always another Megan present
this never bothered me much as a child
because we were pretty easily
distinguished by our last initial I'm
now in my third year of college and I've
just recently found out that there are
21 people named Megan Johnson at my
college - Megan Johnson college three of
which have my same middle initial my
question is how can I become the ruler
of the Megan Johnsons and differentiate
myself as the best Megan Johnson among
those at my university duplicates and
dragon fruits Megan I'm well first of
all I gotta say if your last name is
Johnson you got a name your kid
something weird like you just got to
yeah you can't name it you can't name a
kid jonard or ste well probably Steve
would be okay these days but certainly
not Megan and not any like you got a
look at the rolls and be like anything
in the top hundred is out because you
know you're setting your child up for
this situation sure so many crazy
mothers out there so what are you gonna
you got a name your your offspring
something that isn't isn't common you
got a I think orange it can't rhyme with
it's very similar to my son's name
weirdly announcer son his name is Oren
and his left in his initial of his last
name is G so he's like orange e I mean
it was not on purpose just to be very
clear no sure it wasn't I'm sure because
you're a big Warren G fan you thought
this would be yeah sure this question
there's two ways to go with it there's
for Greg Miller Lee's there's a college
way I differentiated myself
and then my post-college way because
obviously I graduate college I want to
go into the world of video game
journalist I'm going to be online
there's a million Greg Miller's and I
need to get to the top of Google search
results but above me was at number one
Greg Miller lock-picker for begin at
lock-picker
block picking here beginners which was
just a book about lockpick picking okay
number two was Greg Miller Elvis
impersonator in Vegas number three was
Greg Miller who had Greg Miller column
four Greg Miller photography and I
thought I would never be able to usurp
but on the internet it was simple Megan
just take your shirt off a lot and talk
about BB bunch of people follow you on
Twitter and you beat it that way in
college when I went to college I wasn't
worried so much about how do I
differentiate myself from Greg Miller
it was just like who do I want to be at
college and now a little bit of a
prologue to this I went to Catholic
school so I wore uniforms from
kindergarten to 12th grade till I
graduated high school so I graduate high
school feeling liberated when I can find
I'm going I'm going to college now I can
wear whatever I want I can be whoever I
want the man I decide to be is this I
walk in to my dormitory at the
University of Missouri okay it's a hot
day in the end August you're getting
ready to start a new school year I walk
in and from foot to head it goes like
this I'm wearing red converse high tops
I am wearing tube socks up to the middle
of my shin mm-hmm I am wearing jean
shorts
you know t-shirts were not in style back
then I just wore them I am then wearing
a wrestling t-shirt probably the WCW
invasion angle I was a big fan of that
however over the wrestling t-shirt Hank
I am wearing a Hawaiian shirt which
which I bought seven and you might say
why would why and would you buy seven
more shirts because Hank I said when I
was finally out of out from underneath
this uniform
oppression I said I'm gonna go to
college and everyday everyday Hank I am
going to wear a Hawaiian shirt over my
wrestling shirts
superhero shirts whatever shirt some way
and you may say hey Greg why would you
make this choice and the choice was
based on an episode of The Simpsons
where Homer where Homer says to Marge
when Bart is wearing a Hawaiian shirt
Marge only two kinds of people wear
Hawaiian shirts big fat party animals
and gay guys and I said I don't want to
go to college you'd be a big fat party
now you might think next the cooter on
the top of the story then the black rim
glasses I still wear to this day guys
look awesome but then my hair is bright
blue Milhouse blue I graduated high
school I said no more uniforms I can do
whatever I want I bleached my hair I
dyed it blue and I wore up that way for
a year and a half on the university
Missouri campus maybe I'm not saying you
need to do this to differentiate so now
that you know no it was very different I
mean I will tell you that I did I did
not that but uh but it similarly I I you
know I went to a regular public school
so I got to wear whatever I wanted in
high school and but I also even in high
school were like intentionally in like
attention grabbing items of terrible
clothing and you know I think it's some
to some extent please look at me I look
obviously if you become fairly popular
on the internet it's possible that you
have a little bit of a please look at me
desire so so do you want a question to
ask yourself
Megan is do you want to be the leader of
the Megan Johnsons so if you're sure you
want that I think you will start being
the leader of the Megan Johnston's would
that have you our same middle initial
and then and then they become you're
sort of like brain trust and then that
small group can go and take over all the
rest of the Megan Johnston's but the
good news is that like taking over
taking over 21 people it's not that hard
I mean people take up a whole take over
whole nations so usually you start
somewhere I don't
Johnston's together on the quad or
whatever then knock out the tallest one
the second prison Johnson's I was
worried this was gonna go like red
wedding on us and I was like just
punching his stranger because she has
your name you know the other thing too
Megan just say you the rights daughter
and then everybody's gonna be like oh my
gosh that's Dwayne Johnson's daughter
like we have to befriend her she's be
Megatron
yes oh that's it can you kid is that a--
is that a passable lie like like it is a
pretty information dense world these
days I feel like people can figure it
out but I feel like there's gotta be
something you can say you're fine angle
of it you know yeah exactly just like
just like just like edit that Wikipedia
page every single morning yeah before
TMZ all right this for another one no
I'm gonna I'm gonna hit you with our
sponsors Greg cuz its partner Ron to you
by Megan Johnson daughter of Dwayne the
rock Johnson available at university
leading all Meghan Johnson's there and
everywhere it's also brought to you by
water it's dry I guess also brought to
you by Eugene levees eyebrows slowly
trying to crawl upon my own face if I'm
correct you know you dear restaurants
when you've had a baby god yes I did not
remember that reference that had left I
was like what are you talking about but
yeah when you're telling the story
they interrupt but when you tell the
story you're like I was sitting there
eating I could be eating I could be
eating ice just this weird mineral that
we just eat in order to not be dry on
the inside so weird
it's podcast good wet I could wet my
eyes this podcast is additionally
brought to you by our actual sponsor
Casper
you've heard of Casper probably it is a
sleep brand it's revolutionising its
line of products to create exceptionally
comfortable sleep experiences for people
one night at a time they have mattresses
but they also have things that aren't
mattresses like pillows and other
sleep-related activity objects
cash flow products are designed by
humans for humans and with over 20,000
reviews and an average of 4.8 stars
across Casper Amazon and Google Casper
is becoming the Internet's favorite
mattress you can spend one 30-year life
sleeping so you should be comfortable
during that time at Casper mattresses
are perfectly designed for humans and
engineered to soothe and cradle your
natural geometry affordable prices
because Casper cuts out that middleman
and sells directly to you and shipping
is free and returns are free as long as
you're in the US and Canada you can be
sure of your purchase with Casper's 100
night risk-free sleep on it trial you
get that mattress you try it out and you
can send it back and get all your money
back if you don't like it start sleeping
ahead of the curve with Casper get fifty
dollars toward any mattress purchase but
visiting Casper comm / to your Hank or
if you really want to Casper calm / to
your John but why wouldn't you he's not
even here and using the coupon code dear
Hank or Dear John at checkout terms and
conditions apply that's $50 off at
Casper dot-com slash dear Hank with the
coupon code dear Hank uh
it if you want to use Dear John you can
but I don't understand why you would do
that to me because you want to reply as
a respect to show up if he was a respect
to show up yeah I sleep out of Casper
ventures yeah but do you that's fine
with me as long as you don't send people
to a different link
[Laughter]
nice do you like your Casper mattress oh
I love it
the best part was unboxing it you open
it up and it just inflates in front of
you does not seem natural yeah the
future of mattresses are here thanks to
Casper first support in the podcast and
and for supporting lots of different
podcasts because it's good to have a
robust podcast industry because we we
need quality audio content in our lives
yeah you want to talk to people I need
to listen to something to distract me
from the fact that I will someday die
it's just it's gotta distract people
from it when they're the library stared
as weird meet photo like what is that
neat it's so weird
oh good super weird don't eat meat in
the library especially if it's not
alright let's just let's it let's it
like one or two more questions I don't
know how long we've been recording
because my recording is set to two
measures so we've been we've been
recording for 1430 two measures at 120
beats per minute so I believe that
equates to about 46 minute okay thank
you for doing the conversion alarming
alright look guy one more one or two
more questions before we get to the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon this one
comes from Jackie who asks dear Hank a
Greg whenever it rains snails
start appearing all over the concrete
and in my steps leading in my front door
I worry for them water pools on the
concrete and I the word that the snails
are gonna drown what are they trying to
flee
should I relocate them to a nearby
potted plant or are they just out for a
nice stroll and should I leave them be
memento mori including snails Jacky
ma'am you what you guys you guys write
about weird stuff weird weird stuff I
mean snails are of garden pests like
they're the thing that gives you plants
well but like yeah we do it really
slowly
those the ones depends on what shirt if
you got like cabbage man snails and
slugs are the worst you open up your
cabbage
I thought I was gonna have this
beautiful cabbage and instead I have
like a weird slug ball and it's mostly
slug and that's not what that's not what
that's not what I worked all year
watering this thing for good point
i-i-i guess that the snails are trying
to stay dry
ah because because the rain is wet it's
gonna snails
yeah it does it's weird to me it appears
when I lived in Florida this is not the
case in Montana because it we barely
rains ever here when it would rain it
will just be like where did these things
come from where were they like - were
they just like born by there did they
fall out of this guy and then you have
to worry about them dying or getting
stepped on or just they're everywhere
and it actually sometimes I feel like I
can I could smell the smell of all the
snails that died after being rainstorm
terrible sure awful weird snot smell
yeah yeah you don't think they're out
there and then when it does rain and
they come out that's me like where have
you all been hiding what were you up to
what are you plotting what is that where
is the where is the magicals
like snail wonderland where you all hang
out when it's dry and that gets flooded
every time it rains and worries about
you trying to flee the rain are these
shoppers
I'm always whenever I see a snail out in
the rain on the sidewalk at streetlights
it's one of those like like it's one of
those rare occurrences where I can see
to the future you're gonna get smooshed
it's not me but someone's gonna step on
you you're gonna get hit by a car yeah
should I just stay wherever you were I
know you're worried about drowning you
know you you know they breathe through
their skin most the times they need to
get away from it but like you're you're
in trouble buddy you're in trouble I do
like Jackie I will commend you on your
on your sympathy for the match for like
protecting snails from the natural
processes in which they will die but do
remember they'll die no matter what and
so will everything sure that's part of
life death is part of life I can't
believe you lettin caterpillars off so
easy that I guess it's cuz my mom had
these big room
plants and the caterpillars would get on
those leaves and eat those and I always
wanted to prove our cobbler so I was
always anti caterpillar way more than
the attack snail I feel ya I feel ya
what we I guess we have both of those
problems here in Montana I don't know
slugs are just wet grocer you know like
you don't like you cut there so sluggy
but no I agree if if you're trying to
feed humans with plants those those
organisms are not your friends and yeah
so that's that's why I just let somebody
else grow on my food now I'll try I
don't try to do that anymore
it's too much let's just so much work
you got us monitor it you look for these
guys I'll take it change it for you here
so one time I was out at the Kankakee in
Kankakee River
can you feel annoyed we caught a bunch
of snails uh-huh I thought I would bring
them home and put them into the aquarium
of my aquatic turtle pokey too I put him
into pokey twos aquarium went to bed
woke up the next day KT Mills nails that
me that's great it all was a pretty
chill turtle that I also got freak a
Kiki River so you thought these guys
would have some kind of Kankakee River
communal agreement that they're all
gonna just chill out they remember each
other that was not the case maybe the
snails had escaped I was looking for
slime trails out of the aquarium and
then it was just became clear no nobody
ate them
well that's talking bear oh that's great
you can keep going getting Kankakee
snails or whatever that word was yes and
bringing them back you know you know you
don't have to buy off to buy a turtle
food anymore
he's got snails yeah that's a good point
again I mean what do you think there is
she gives what do you think Polk hurdle
is eaten when he was in the river yeah
we never talked about it
we kidnapped him you know I'm he's a
very small turtle we got I kind of feel
bad looking back on that but then again
I don't know how turtles really roll if
they have a family thing and I know what
your listeners are thinking I'm talking
about pokey to was the original pokey
his brother in the river
no original pokey was a box turtle who
lived in aquarium next to pokey too so
they were brothers that I brought
together
but not brothers my blood right they
weren't even they weren't even species
brothers correct yeah yeah and pokey one
was just just like a store turtle yeah
yeah I'm just you just chill she liked
to eat carrots one time we put her in
the backyard my dad fence straight with
chicken wire so she'd be out in the
grass nicely you know what about our day
and then we came back and cheat escaped
no and like there is there was a moment
of panic but then we remembered that all
pokey ever wanted to do was hibernate so
we just went to the darkest corner that
we could find in the ER - sure enough
there she was asleep yeah I had to
escape so that I could relax
I had to rest of jailbreak so that I can
sleep good I'm very slow geo break to
the side of the house all right Greg did
you bring us news from AFC Wimbledon
I have breaking news oh boy are you
ready yeah all right the headline is
Neil sums up his disappointment after
defeat at Yoko Ono this is by Chris
Lavin of course Emile Ardley concluded
that it was a former team performance
from one was his much charged lineup at
Yeovil Town after last night's
checkatrade
trophy exit speaking during a interview
for my follow after last night's 200
loss Neil said the next team won they
were much more at it than us in every
way both physically and mentally it was
a poor performance to many players who
had not play the first team level for a
while seemed to be a bit rusty we played
players out of position which was hard
because of my lack of players we had but
that's no excuse
there is loads to learn from it lots of
development for the younger boys but the
best team won ouch
ooh rough one you know I mean you can't
get a W yo you got problems that's right
yeah absolutely like yeah I know nothing
about that at all but I ya know none of
this made sense to me at all
I know I acted well the good news is
that AFC Wimbledon has got getting a
bunch of a bunch of money coming up soon
because they've they've pulled a very
good draw in the FA Cup so they're gonna
play in a very big stadium against a
very big team
so they get half the money and so
instead of the normal like four thousand
tickets they're gonna sell like eighty
thousand or something ridiculous so good
that that will hopefully allow them to
invest in in some players I think John's
gonna talk more about that next week on
the podcast if they come out in the
order that I believe they're going to
come out in in Mars news Greg do you
want to know about the Mars news that I
found it's really weird
I should just search for for Mars on a
hello poetry and see what happens that
should be like look I bet you so there's
gonna be a lot more I will show you that
a few months planning baby kiss me like
we're on Mars and the only breath we
have is from each other's lungs Oh leo
oh dammit +23
with with 2.3 thousand likes or
something on whatever platform that's it
whatever that icon is it's got two point
three thousand sorry I got distracted
from my actual Mars news which is that
you know Buzz Aldrin right I do know
Buzz Aldrin personally so he he went to
the moon and he's doing a brand deal
right now which I love that he's Buzz
Aldrin he's doing a brand deal he's
doing a brand deal with spray in 2017
yeah he's doing a sprayground a new
york-based accessories label so that
second human Dilys step on the moon is
doing his first and only fashion
collaboration a mission to Mars themed
capsule line and when they say capsule I
think they mean back Pat well I don't
know actually what a casul line is so
there's a backpack with solar panels on
it a duffel bag a baseball cap in gloves
all emblazoned with a colorful
assortment of patches including one
featuring all turns face in the words
moon Mars and Beyond and I've gone to
spray Graham's collaborations page
sprayground comm / collaboration tous
les bud buzz - Aldrin - mission - to -
Mars dot html' which will later
which will I'll probably link to on the
patreon because oh my god it's so cool
he said like a freaking hover car and
these hot ladies have guns and some
clearly cybernetic armor and they're all
wearing this very very cool but also
pretty nerdy backpack that I'd almost
definitely am going to buy there's also
a mission the mission to Mars shark
patches parka Buzz Aldrin collab also
very cool the the solar power backpack
is coming soon the non solar bout
powered backpack is available now for
$80 and the gloves are only twenty bucks
and they're really freaking cool oh man
I didn't expect it like this as much as
I do I know right
it feels weird this is definitely
something that like Greg Miller would
totally have worn freshman year of
college
all right well this was a bad brand deal
that we didn't get paid for but
sprayground this is doing a very cool
mission to Mars mission to Mars fashion
collab with Buzz Aldrin who's sitting in
his amazing space chair however that got
made oh man the world the universe is
such a wonderful place I'm gonna have in
its shorts don't make me sad Dirk
there's like shark bites all over the
place uh I I've got oh man I'm upset
that I'm gonna have to wait until this
podcast comes out to tweet about this
Yeah right but wonderful so that that's
that's the news from Mars Greg can you
tell me like what exactly we learned
today on this podcast if anything water
is definitively wet all right you can if
they want
so that's the thing you learn I'm pretty
sure that water is joining I know in
fact I did tweet about water being dried
during this podcast and I kind of want
to see what the responses to that have
been my friend
I was just riot my friend Tahoe looks
like he's maybe a little bit frustrated
with me and what else we got it's
non-alcoholic
so it's dry in the sense like a dry
County that's good David says the earth
is a triangle just to come back at me in
I have to say it's maybe not my best
performing tweet I feel like it's really
like coming in significantly under the
bar with 300 likes usually I'm doing
better than you know I love you I
respect you you built an empire you're
amazing you're a coward if you were a
man you would have made this whole my
friend Greg Miller just responded to
this tweet with just two two characters
and a punctuation it's and O period so
somebody's gotta say it
waters dry I think water might be dry
we're really excited to defend this
terrible opinion for years and years to
come
yeah I'm ready to have some different
arguments on the internet right now I'm
done I've done with the okay and we also
learned we also learned that uh that you
shouldn't touch your rustic bread with
raw meat in a library
great point we also learned about a
great site called hello poetry column oh
we learned how about hello poacher comm
I feel really weird they didn't know
more about hello poetry until now and
finally we imagine for you guys finally
we learned that Buzz Aldrin is still
working it right now fashion model a
space astronaut Buzz Aldrin
thank you for potting with me Greg
Miller this was a absolutely joy and
very fun it's been a pleasure thank you
so much for having all right this
podcast is produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson it's edited by
nicholas jenkins our head of community
and communications is victoria bon
giorno you can find out more about dear
Hank and John at patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John where you could also
support us and get our occasional 5 to
10 minute very bad podcast that is only
for patrons called this week in Ryans
you can also you can also send us
questions at Hank and John at gmail.com
I am Hank green on Twitter John as John
Green
Greg is I think game over Greg e on
Twitter if you want to if you want to
get some of that going on and you can
find out all about kind of funny all
over the place they make hilarious stuff
that's really fun and one more thing the
theme music that you're hearing right
now is from the great gunnarolla and
also the music at the beginning and as
they say on our hometown
[Applause]
[Music]